so the 73rd episode is coming around now
and at this point I think we kind of
need to think about what kind of
direction I really want to take the pike
into because I've mainly been doing this
in the comments and stuff but that isn't
really the most efficient way to
communicate things especially not food
those people just watching it so I just
can't wait to solidify my ideas about
how I'm going to do this Pike right now
and the more I feel like I communicate
with others and whatever I want to do
with this bike the more I also become
pretty sure that that isn't the kind of
thing that I want to do with it so yeah
let's just roll that the first thing I
kind of want to do here is like I said
just doing main street but then after
that I went to branch into like all the
different areas that I want to build in
the park and one thing is for sure it's
going to be based on different areas in
the world I'm pretty much set on the
head room right now the only issue is
what kind of areas do I want to do and
how many do I want to do because I don't
want to keep going forever and ever and
ever and I feel like that also needs to
be some way in which it is organized for
example putting all the Asian countries
in one corner of the park and all the
European countries etc stuff like that
and what I want to do attractions wise
is something just kind of similar just
whatever people suggests and I feel like
that could actually work is something
that I'll think about and possibly try
so it's going to be a bit of a balance
because I don't want to make things that
I really don't want to make or feel that
wouldn't work in this park but that
still means that you know suggestions
never work out because I like to listen
to them and sometimes I just forget
about Costa type so whatever things I
could do so I'm still quite glad
whenever people give suggestions not to
mention the fact that sometimes people
do kind of show me some mistakes that I
didn't think of myself I have been
building a lot of inverted coasters as
it lately so I might want to kind of
calm down on that one
though to be very honest if I really
feel like it and if an inverted coaster
would work in this Park I'm still going
to do it probably but yeah that's one of
the things I want to get at least one
B&M coaster and it's probably going to
be just one because I feel like it would
be overkill if I started placing via
Namco's
all over in the smoke but I at least
want to have something there is this one
idea about having a Disney style park
though honestly it has a bit of a mix of
Europa Park and Busch Gardens but I'd
like to talk about that later on and
having hit B and M coaster in it that's
just so great because I think and I kind
of understand this many people like this
knee but the thing that they're missing
about it is the rollercoasters it kind
of favors the scenery and the entire
atmosphere and ambience of the park over
the roller coasters and the thrilling
rides in general thrilling rides that is
not even a word what am I saying
but that is something that I want to get
in there because I always got both sides
I still want to focus on scenery because
that is the thing that I like most but
you know that there's this thing about
big roller coasters that work out with
scenery that it's also very appealing
and something that I want to try because
it's challenging nonetheless so I want
to do that as well there is going to be
at least one beam M coaster that's
either going to be an invert might be a
flyer but it's not very likely I've kind
of given up on that idea and another
idea that I got from some people is to
do a wing rider and this is also
something that I really want to try
because you don't really see too many
very well themed wing riders I don't
think there's any wing rider that really
has have a heavy theming in a way that a
might train coaster for example has
heavy theming and this is something that
I would like to mess around with
especially with the hitboxes of the cars
and stuff like that you can really do
some fun things with that I think some
other some other ideas were to build a
bnm hyper coaster but this is something
that I'm probably not going to do
because even though I like them and they
they look pretty cool it just doesn't
really work out with a heavily themed
park there is no way you can build a B&M
hyper coaster and theme it all the way
because those things are just so
incredibly huge you can't really do too
many things with those things and a B
and M sit down kind of goes the same for
it I mean it's still not as big as a bnm
hypo but it's still pretty big coaster
usually usually so that could work out
but those things never really have as
much senior interaction as for example
IBM input has because some really big B
and I'm in vert still have some really
cool scenery
I guess alpengeist would be a very nice
sir
of that and what I talked about earlier
when I said that this part is going to
be a mixture of Disney and Europa Park
and Busch Gardens possibly some more
things probably a lot of efteling even
if I don't want to do it it's probably
going to get there subconsciously
because that's actually the only park on
that list that I've actually been to but
yeah I kind of like those parks all
because they have really good scenery
and you know how much I like my scenery
and Disney is going to be that main
influence in the sense that you know
what I'm doing right now building a Main
Street stuff like that having the
differently themed areas this knee is
also the kind of path work that I want
to do in this game in this park at least
because I've looked at different parks I
always actually build an ode and I went
up to Google Maps and checked out some
theme parks and I was pleasantly
surprised that I could actually check
out all those things in Google Maps why
even go there when you can just look at
them the Internet but then it turned out
that Disney actually had some paw of
style that works well in roller coaster
kethry and I think it works better than
the other ones because it's it spread
out you can still see all the things and
you can still take some nice shots with
it with the flying camera route editor
but it isn't as compacts and packed with
foliage as for example Busch Gardens is
and and then I'm talking about Busch
Gardens Williamsburg by the way I am
completely ignoring the other one I'm
sorry about all the fans of that park
that's still a really good part but it's
not the type of park that I'm going for
it least not in a sinner themed sense
and the thing with the Busch Gardens
Williamsburg is that it's really great
and I like it but it's so compact and it
has that much foliage that I feel like a
park like that wouldn't really work out
too well in rollercoaster 3 you do at
least kind of want to show off your
buildings and attractions in a way that
you actually have nice views and stuff
like that and Busch Gardens Williamsburg
I think it's in the middle of a forest
and that's not really what I want to go
for and I do want to have some gardens
in this park though this is one Park in
America but I completely forgot the name
which had awesome gardens but nothing
else really the mail I did I forget the
name anyway that's something that I also
want to get somewhere in the park at
Leeson various different areas just an
area similar to how the efteling does it
without any attractions aside from
maybe an observation deck or a little
boat ride or a little vehicle other
things whatever the cool kids have these
days and Gardens because I really like
to go into gardening that's is something
that I'm going to do more often to some
slightly secluded areas in the park that
there are not too easy to get that not
too many people go to but then if you're
in the park and it's quite busy you can
still find some relaxing areas and
nature and have a core picnic now it's
basically the idea behind that and now I
realize that I've been talking about all
this park stuff for a very long time and
even haven't even talked about the main
street itself I guess I can say some
small things about the buildings that I
am building right now the idea that I
want to keep with this Main Street is
it's going to be a weird kind of melting
pot of all the different cultures at
least in Europe I don't want to get too
many other things in there like if I put
an Asian building in there I feel like
it would be a bit too awkward and it
would stand apart too much from the rest
of the Main Street so I kind of don't
want to do that but still you can
probably see some influences from
different places and there's a bit of
American Main Street ich miss out of
there I guess but yeah the buildings
that I have so far is that one Victorian
building which I don't even know if that
is really inspired by a particular
country at all I didn't even know
exactly where that would work out it
seemed like a very theme park ish
building the building with the green
walls next to the building that I'm
building right now is a Scandinavian ish
building it was actually I went into it
thinking this is going to be a Baltic
building with the colours being like
that and it having that standard roof
kind of texture I mean roof shape that
points toward the street or in usual
cases it would be square but I guess
that's also kind of more European in
general and the rest of the buildings on
this side of the street so far just kind
of standard-issue Main Street buildings
there's not really too much to them and
then there's the Germanic building kind
of thing with the castle tower just to
break that up kind of that and that was
a bit of a boring building without that
castle tower standard type of Germanic
building didn't really want to have that
and of course there's the Romanian theme
in the entrance though I don't really
think I'm going to put too many remain
influences in the rest of the park but
yeah it's really hard to nail down the
themes of the various buildings because
okay I did a lot of Google Maps research
actually for this park and you'd be kind
of surprised unless you already know
about this how similar many European
cities are they all kind of have a
similar classical build up in terms of
both the city layout and the buildings
and it's hard to really get too many
distinct buildings in the main street
without the Main Street not looking
coherent so yeah I don't want to mess
with that too much the building in the
front though still kind of reminds me of
Austrian buildings I don't know exactly
what it was but it might be the color
scheme that's still my favorite only no
I'm pretty glad that even though it was
the first building and all the buildings
after it weren't really as great as that
one building in my opinion it's still
cool to have that good building on the
corner that's kind of where you do want
to go for the best buildings are going
to be on the corner and going to get the
most of the attention and then the kind
of okay hmm yeah buildings are going to
be on the sides and just not the
direction but just form a call facade
but yeah that's it for this episode I'll
see you on the next one and thank you
for watching